you know the subject burnout typically
tracks two different types of people
that say hey you know what this poor
enough subject I really want to know a
lot about because one there's a group
that always thinks they're burnout yeah
I'm really going through burnout right
now and you don't understand things are
so hard because I'm burning out and then
there's the other audience that says I'm
confused I'm not burned out what's going
on I can push more but I think
regardless both audiences can get a lot
from today's video so stay with me here
because I must say a lot of different
things that may be on one side
contradicting some of your mindset and
another one give you a couple tools that
can help you go through the process or
Berna
so first let's process who goes through
burnout number one as a person as a
perfectionist a perfectionist if
everything isn't going perfect they're
not happy so this is just how they're
wired and they feel everything needs to
be perfect instead of magical they're
always wanting perfection the other one
is a pessimist a pessimist no matter
what you ever get them nothing's ever
happy everything could be going right
kids are doing good families doing good
business Currier they're never happy
because they're pessimist it's a mindset
it's a way of thinking the other one's a
control freak
the control freak you know anything big
that expands you have to lose control of
anything big whatever expand you
eventually lose control so if your
business is growing at some point you
lose a little bit of control when your
kids are aging and they're going to
school creating their own opinions
you're going to lose control of your
kids like you said when they're eight
years old or five years old you don't
have control over your kids at 16 years
old like you once used to have but you
got to let go of it or else it's going
to drive you nuts and you're not going
to enjoy your life as a parent you want
to enjoy you won't even enjoy these guys
growing up or the type-a personality
super competitive and sometimes the
type-a personality will compare
themselves to somebody who is 72 and
you're 64 you're never going to be 72 to
someone who jumps 43 inches and you only
jump 16 inches
you can't ever do that so why are you
comparing yourself to that to somebody
who comes from a family with a lot of
wealth and you don't they don't need me
you're so competitive that you're
comparing in every area instead of
competing with what you got and winning
you do a lot of comparing that sometimes
happens to type-a personality so now the
cause what is the cause of burnout
sometimes I make like what is neglect
neglect meaning
I eat fast food every day at Burger King
and McDonald's and I eat so many
different burgers I put on 39 pounds my
energy is low I'm lethargic I don't have
energy I'm burn out that is neglect
because of your diet neglect because you
haven't done a date night with your girl
for the last six months that's neglect
neglect could be you haven't talked to
your kids or conversations with them
neglect any of that stuff that's purely
a cause you're neglecting number two's
overload overload could be always taking
on more projects always taking on more
friendships always taking on more
businesses people doing five businesses
at the same time three different jobs at
the same time all this stuff instead of
focusing on killing one of them and
doing a very good job
it's overload that can cause it as well
number three is lack of growth if you're
not growing you're not seeing something
growing there's nothing exciting about
life because nothing is growing so if
you're not developing yourself while
you're growing your bit while your
business is going with it soon but
you're not developing you're not seeing
progress in you that causes burnout
because like why am I putting myself
through this why am i doing what I'm
doing right now working out if you keep
going out to the gym and nothing happens
you don't see results there could be a
burnout because you're not seeing your
body improving based on the hours you're
putting into the gym the other one is
newness life needs excitement life needs
new things new experience has seen a new
world of reading a new book you know
said certain things that cause newness
in a family that's exciting there's new
things to be looking forward to there's
new things to be looking forward with
business with life then it's figment of
your imagination let me tell you why I
added this one here on cause what causes
it you create a problem that doesn't
exist you sabotage yourself to create
something that doesn't exist and you
make it a massive problem but it's
purely your imagination taking control
your mind and that turns into a burnout
because you created this enemy you
created the animal in your mind it
doesn't exist by the way most people who
think they're burning out they're having
created this figment of their
imagination into a massive problem
that's non-existent
that's cause now let's talk about people
you go to every time there's some that
happens in our lives a crisis a victory
a
los a setback whatever happens we
typically are going to go and speak to
three different types of people okay
there is the downer the upper the
Socratic listener let me explain to what
I mean by this so the downer is somebody
that you know just recently last week
men or business I was going through some
challenging times and the downer says
dude why'd you even go that I told you
this thing never works maybe that guy's
making all the money off you what are
you doing with this thing downer downer
burnout burnout yeah you're right it
eventually stays right why are you doing
this man this sucks you put your you
putting it you get down the upper is
somebody that no matter what you ever do
they always love you honey you're
amazing I love you
you're great you can do this go get them
you're awesome you're amazing that's a
good person to talk to
then the Socratic person is a person
that you're going through challenges and
you feel like you're burning out they
take all your excuses and your
justification away from you and they ask
you a question are you really going
through a lot of difficult times
is this real what you're going through
are you creating it in your mind do you
really think you're burning out do you
read so they're putting it on you and
you're sitting there it's a little bit
of pushback to you're not too happy
about it but that helping you grow and
overcome this so in your mind this
imagination doesn't become bigger than
it already is they make it smaller
because these guys tend to by asking you
questions and challenging you they make
the primary thing is this big they make
it this big
those are leaders now watch whoever you
go to makes this a bigger event if you
go to the downer this gets bigger if you
go to the upper it alleviates if you go
to the socratic questionnaire it makes
it even smaller my suggestion to you is
just like in sports when a player a
quarterback isn't doing well there's
typically two different types of
personalities on teams that are always
winning that guy's going to go to an
assistant coach where the assistant
coach is going to say something like
this hey listen man you good bro cocaine
and you're awesome go get them man you
were meant to do this you're an amazing
quarterback you can pull this up if you
do this all the time do what you don't
practice Johnny you're right and in
other coaches that's going to be after
the game hey listen what happened why do
you handle that why'd you pass it over
there what would we do in practice
did you really practice did you practice
out how you think if you were to
practice you would have been to this you
need both right but
you go to the guy that says dude that's
the worst coach of all time you need to
leave that team you need to do this well
you're getting right here so now this is
who this is cause this is who we go to
when we have issues now here's some
things that can possibly help you out -
not necessarily overcome a burnout but
to not even get there and not even
experience that and by the way I would
much rather burnout and rust out of my
life I wouldn't try to go so hardcore in
my life where I experience a little bit
of burnout then I do something that
nothing big with my life and eventually
I rust out and I die I don't want to be
that person you don't either by the way
the only way you really figure out what
the maximum potential of you is by
pushing your limits at times and
sometimes the great ones have to do it
that's if you want to be great so let's
go through some of these points number
one number one
protect your yeses let me explain what I
mean by protect you yeses you know how
they say sometimes hey you know she was
easier he is easier and this stuff don't
be easy if somebody ask you can you do
this don't say yes to everybody you're
giving it up too easy protect it a
little bit right protect your yeses say
yes as two people that matter that don't
typically ask you to do things for the
hell of it there's a lot of people that
always want to ask you for favors for
nothing it's always asking for favors
and help but there's never and returning
not only that it's not really things
that produce the best types of results
so protect your yeses on who you give
yes to number two turn off your phone
actually turn off your phone this thing
can be a big distraction in your life
turn this thing off and meditate or pray
I mean I can tell you when it was
September of 2000 September of 1997 I
was in the army I was going through hell
on a bootcamp a bomb I said there's not
a lot of things good that's going on in
my life I don't believe in God I don't
believe in faith but I started praying
like this god I don't believe you exist
but you know what I'm gonna talk to you
odds are you're not there if you are
maybe you can answer my prayers ty
started because a guy in the Army you
know told me to start praying that I
don't believe it to just try it out you
know what happened it was therapeutic
just me talking to myself and praying
meditating and have a my quiet time it
allowed me to go through difficult times
of being in a military by myself at a
unit where everybody's either from
Mississippi Tennessee North Dakota South
Dakota the right black and I'm Iranian
okay and I'm going from Iran where are
you from Iran Iran like Iran yes what
are you doing in the arm I'm going to do
this that allows me to just be able to
overcome a difficult time like this I
wouldn't experience a part of this in my
life and then I enjoy I ended up
enjoying my experience in boot camp AIT
and the army it ended up being one of
the best things in my life but I needed
some quiet time you need some quiet
times a time number three children I
don't know what happens when I'm around
kids it brings out the childlike
tendencies of ours and all of us
typically have a little bit of childlike
when you're around kids you tend to
forget about your problems if I wrestle
with my kids for 15 20 30 minutes it is
so therapeutic it's amazing go
contribute to kids go give back to
community do something with kids go to
your nephew or your niece your kids your
neighbor whatever it is play with them
playing Lego with them playing nonsense
stuff that they're playing just do that
with them you come down fairly quickly I
can't tell you how therapeutic that is
next one
quarterly getaways especially if you got
a girl a husband or a wife and what I
what I used to do is quarterly Saturday
afternoon I was done I'd leave Saturday
afternoon go stay at a hotel then come
back Sunday night so it was a day and a
half that I would do per quarter but I
was rejuvenated I was fired up and that
typically might get away has to do with
there's something here to do with sparks
or southern country spa when I was on my
getaway I go to a spa I'd get a massage
I'd get a facial I'd come back and I'm
relaxed Quarterly's regularly that was
phenomenal and annually your work hard
go travel I mean I've been all over the
world when I travel Mario you know this
Croatia Santorini Athens masa novia
Venice Italy Guatemala Jalisco and I
report about the corner Kauai Maui st.
Maarten Caribbean Bahamas Cayman Island
Portugal Spain NASCAR races Disney World
Kentucky Derby Super Bowl Pebble Beach
Dubai you know tusks so many different
places all these places I travel to and
we normally would do one a year or
sometimes you know what it would do you
know what it would do it's just crazy in
history it's great seeing the world it
was fun it was around other people who
are winning you had a chance to release
enjoy yourself eat good food there was
something to look forward to there was a
carrot there was a victory this always
helped done I know sometimes guys there
are certain channels you watch and
certain people I give feedback words
like no I'm 24/7 screw vacation screw
this screw that I don't know that I'm
going to do this till the day I die I
don't subscribe to that mindset I think
you've got to also work your tail off
and have victories and those Victor's
got to be being around people that you
enjoy being around and seeing the world
with the people that you doing business
with next go somewhere to gain
perspective this is very good for
burnout let me tell what this is it
doesn't matter what it is go to the
worst part of town and contribute go to
a homeless shelter and contribute go to
a go to foster home go to hospital where
it's the worst level the hospital these
are on their deathbed and they simply
want to talk to somebody go to senior
home go somewhere to gain perspective go
to a third world country and see what
it's like I'll never forget when I want
to go out a mullah and we went to the
worst part of the city you gain
perspective you gain perspective and you
realize what's really going on what life
is really all about you think your life
is really that hard until you go to
places and say dude I'm burnout are you
kidding me I'm in heaven what am i
complaining about you know we think life
is so hard and we sometimes forget the
fact that our soldiers in Iraq or
Afghanistan or in the you know lines
enemy lines that haven't seen their kids
for 12 18 24 months the birth of their
child they missed and you think what
you're going through is hard because you
work in 80 90 hundred hours a week for
six months straight perspective
sometimes makes you realize this is why
I told you the burnout people are not
going to like this video that tell ya
I'm really going through burnout
perspective getting some perspective for
yourself next gratitude nothing like
gratitude what do you grant grateful for
like right now life family kids
relationship wash our food bed I
remember I was in the field in the Army
for a long long
not a bed not nothing you know we
showered with baby wipes okay you know
baby wipes don't clean everything you
know so there's not really a bathroom
you're going to it's the back forty so
it's like anyways I don't want to get
too disgusting I remember when I came
back after the first time I went to the
field
I took a one and a half hour hot shower
I just put my hand up in the water
hitting my head and you see the entire
bottom is dirt and smell and closes
nasty to the point that even if you
could wash your uniform it's still
disgusting because you got to wash it
over and over and over with downy and
all this other mess that's shower for an
hour and a half and that sleep on you in
your bed at night heavenly but it made
me realize man when's the last time you
were grateful for your mattress your bed
your shower hot water gratitude really
takes a lot of pressure off music
depends on what kind of music you listen
to maybe yours is shoddy
maybe it's Mozart Beethoven maybe it's a
moonlight sonata I don't know what it is
that brings you calms you down have some
kind of taste of music I probably don't
recommend Luisa stays Lewis would
probably listen to Tupac a term up but
he's got a complete different style
Mario on the other Mari what would you
listen to month Metallica give me a song
sanitarian what do you think Paul would
listen to what's Paul spaced boy stur
man I would say probably bullish tomato
Kenny G or some like that Paul would
listen to okay so now what are we over
here now here's my handwriting okay
comedy humor you know how you have that
one friend that just makes you laugh
it's cool to sometimes be when you got a
lot of pressure man and you got a
comedian next to you let me tell you
everything is gone right go to a comedy
club on a Saturday night and just say
look I just want to go to a place have a
beer and just listen to a bunch of jokes
relax come back or find a way to watch a
video prank something that calms you
down humor has a lot of power when
you're going through a mode like this
next to simplify life let me know what I
mean by simplify life look at every
aspect of your life that's complicated
and create systems for it
so who do you let into your life how do
you handle your health how do you handle
doctor dentist how do you handle expand
Bill's insurance kids mom dad family
parents business creates systems for
everything and simplified don't
complicate it simplify things in your
life you see so many weeds and different
aspects of your life why do you have
that pull them out now I'm not dealing
with this anymore simplify your life
okay next minimize relationships I know
this sounds strange for some people here
I am NOT a fan of how it used to be time
I had hundreds of friends and I'm the
type of guy I'm so loyal to my friends
that I want to make sure everybody is
happy and then what I realized this I
was being drained because it was going
like this and it wasn't coming back like
this all the time and I always felt like
it had to make sure my friends were
happy and all my family members were
happy and then I brought it done and I
said the people that matter the most to
me on the family side is my dad my
sister mom niece nephew brother-in-law
that's priority right there okay now
obviously I'm not talking wife and kids
because that's obviously number one
because that's family family okay
friends I looked at the list and I
really went through it I said what
really is genuine about this
relationship we go to do this and what
do we do I can't do this thing I just
can't how about this one here he always
takes he never gives so take take take
the cake and I'm empty every time I'm
done with this one him there's motives I
don't know about this good guy is just
we're at a different phase of our lives
and I minimized it Mari I did a video on
friends what is that video called you
remember something about friends can you
look it up right how to how to choose
great friends
how to choose great friends let's put a
thumbnail of it for you to see highly
recommend everybody watch this video
giving you a better perspective on what
to do with your relationships okay
Paul Louis let's not forget the
thumbnail so people can see it exercise
the more you move you feel better
it's just body movement needs to happen
you feel that I've never once gone to a
gym even when I was not in the mood and
left the gym not feeling good about
myself you probably have never done that
either gym just makes life more exciting
positive distractions what's positive
distractions I don't know minimizing
negative distress
but at some positive distractions a
system that gets you away from prom you
are thinking about that's getting bigger
create some positive distraction systems
in your life
next is seek progress not perfection
pretty obvious it's constant growth so
the more you're growing its progress
don't put the pressure everything being
perfect I mentor a lot of people that
are perfectionist quite frankly their
business never explodes none several of
them for a year saying stop trying to be
perfect and justifying and making
excuses for everything and deflecting
every problem because you want to be so
perfect your business is not going to
explode if you're always trying to
become perfect but businesses grow when
you focus on progress and you enjoy it
more when you focus on progress and
obviously last but not least a spa foot
massage massage whatever you're doing
all that stuff it's figure out a way for
somebody listen you know why our hands
are like this Mary come here real quick
I'm gonna show them something look at
this here look at how the hand is look
at this handshake this is why we're
created the way the way our hands are
ever wonder why both of our hands are
not the same which I imagine my right
and my left is because we're supposed to
go like this this is power this is bond
this feels good it's two of us this
feels very good relationships feel very
good Mario needs a hug right are you
okay don't you guys that's a cool way is
that what it is look at this guy here
man he looks like a gangster today with
his hat from Pacoima where'd you go out
that by the way I put Inglewood copying
religion
Inglewood by highschool you one word our
school was Birmingham high school and
then didn't you invent another like a
Pacoima and Sylmar some of that stuff
but guys like us 13 we don't even tell
your whole story right now hey listen
you know what'd be great someone asked
you how about Mario what about one of
these days you do a video on what it's
like to be working with value tainment
and then you tell the truth everything
the good bad ugly if you would like some
like their comment on the bottom maybe
isn't make comments mario is going to do
an episode mario is going to do an
episode on that human connection is
needed we are made because we need to be
around other human beings that lift us
up as well so strong relationships when
I'm talking about the upper and the
socratic this really makes the soul just
half
man strong good positive relationship I
would much rather have three incredible
friends that I can talk about anything
openly with no judgment then have
thousands of relations and thousands of
friendships that I'm just when I talked
it's just there's always so just
increase the value the relationships
that you have Mari let's throw the
pillow here good throw and by the way
the subject on burnout it is probably
something a lot of other people are
going through as well some of your
employees your executives your staff
your relatives your family it would not
be a bad idea for you to share this
video with some of the people that you
know because I do think this there's no
I don't normally I probably said share
this video maybe on five different
videos in my career this is a video that
many other people will thank you when
you share this with them if you have any
questions or thoughts comment on the
bottom and if you have not subscribed to
this channel yet be sure to subscribe
right here almost in the space be sure
to subscribe right we should have gone
down Luis to hit his face and he knocks
that it would have been so great slow
motion so be sure to click Subscribe
here and the alert button to be notified
every single time a value tainment
episode goes out take everybody
[Music]